I don't know I always have these for
hopefully a cleverish thumbnail also I
can make creepy imagery right here
remember Return to Oz with the wheelers
and [ __ ] freaked me out as a kid there
we go very Devil's Advocate
[Music]
so Halloween ends as part three
otherwise known as the epic-ish
conclusion of this new Halloween Trilogy
in which Lori Strode Michael Myers Clash
for the last time now I'm actually
really conflicted about this review
because at the beginning of the videos I
usually give you the light plot synopsis
with no spoilers but letting you know
what the movie's kind of about and then
I talk about what I liked and didn't
like about the movie that said the
reason I'm conflicted is because in none
of the promotional material has it told
you what the plot actually is for this
movie oh it's Laurie strod versus
Michael might nope I mean it's in there
for a few minutes at the end of the
movie it's not really what it's about
all right I'm mid editing this review
right now there's no other way to do it
I'm just gonna give you the actual plot
synopsis of this movie that said I'm
gonna mark this as light spoiler-ish if
you don't want to know anything about
the movie you want to blissfully go into
Halloween ends and attempt to watch the
film that the trailer showed you which
is not the premise of the film home be
my guest for those of you who want to
know the premise of Halloween ends go
ahead and stick around but just please
don't be pissed you have been warned
that said in that out of the way the
actual plot summary of this movie is
it's been four years since Michael Myers
has last been seen since the last movie
Halloween kills and there's this dude
who's had a run of bad luck we will say
due to unfortunate circumstances people
see him as a monster as an [ __ ] so he
starts dating Lori strode's
granddaughter and Lori strodes like he
seems nice it seems kind of off though
so that's the premise of the movie Lori
Strode starts being like I see something
in this kid that reminds me of Michael
Myers so the question is oh is he gonna
snap is he gonna be a killer like
Michael Myers then the movie starts
begging the question what makes someone
snap what makes a psychopath only thing
is this would be deep character study is
revolving around a character I haven't
met before today and although I thought
the actor did a good good job at having
this bird with a broken wing kind of
persona which makes you empathize with
him but then having a couple moments
where he does seem kind of iffy I
thought he did a good job with that the
film's largely on his shoulders so I
give him props for that but as far as he
goes with the Halloween franchise I did
not clock on for this dude I'm clocking
on for the one who's over there on the
benches sitting in the dugouts all like
man when's coach kind of calling me
already I thought everyone in the movie
did a fine job I mean Jamie Lee Curtis
of course is a standout she's got this
[ __ ] down to a science at this point
science and art happy to say she's
actually in Halloween ends far more than
she was in Halloween kills I felt like
she just kind of got sidelined in her
own movie now is Michael Myers who gets
sidelined in his own movies so there's
that and actually I mean when the
killing starts going down that was
pretty satisfying couple kills in
particular definitely stand out they're
what you're going to remember from the
movie I will say the Lori Strode Michael
Myers fight you know the trailer that
you actually saw that was really good
that was fulfilling that was when I was
actually biting my nails to whole time
and when you have the pitch about this
is Halloween ends you don't know who's
going to live or die if either are if
both are that makes the fight a little
more intense and they actually played
that up really well the hour and a half
preceding that this movie feels like
it's two very unrelated films crammed
into one like someone was like hey man
it's me what's up
I'm good I'm good um do you still have
that script the movie about the the
couple who starts dating and the guy's
kind of weird and people in town don't
really like them and they kind of pick
on him and yeah the dating movie
yep
you still don't have a you don't have an
ending for it that is kind of perfect
because I have a Halloween movie and I
don't have anything but an ending for
that so I say we just marry these two
into one script
and just call it Halloween ends but no
one's gonna make that other movie anyway
that'll be fine
no I mean Myers will show up and do
stuff for the last to act absolutely but
I mean the meantime it'll still
concentrate on The Dating couple Michael
Myers would just be doing [ __ ] all in
the meantime
yeah
no no we're gonna keep that out of the
trailer entirely
no it's not called a bait and switch in
Hollywood that's just in sales for
Hollywood trailers it's just called good
marketing
ask me it'll be fine
yeah we're gonna do this all right we
have ourselves a movie your movie has an
ending my movie has a movie all right
later bye I don't know I wasn't in the
room but it really feels like that phone
call happened in the end couple of kills
I like the fight at the end I like Jamie
Lee Curtis I loved but this movie is a
classic case of what we all used to call
sequelitis 2018 Halloween was a really
good idea with really good execution and
you have a couple of sequels that feel
rushed out and they don't feel like they
have the inspiration that led to the
2018 version I always got to give props
for a big swing even if it feels like a
Miss to me but in execution it is a miss
and I'm not gonna remember it in T-minus
one day yep already forgot Halloween
2018 as Halloween ends for me and that's
perfectly fine Michael Myers comes back
after 40 years Laurie Strode was waiting
for him was prepared traps him in the
basement burns the house down Michael
Myers dies in the fire alright so
Halloween ends what's your favorite
Halloween movie out there or your least
favorite or you can list them that's
always fun YouTubers aren't the only
ones that do lists the comments section
is yours to make lists whatever your
favorite least favorite or Halloween
list is comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
or it's the thing
[Music]